à l'isolément pendant deux semaines
c'est ce que s'apprête à vivre ses
touristes britanniques de retour
d'espagne
une mesure soudaine annoncées par le
gouvernement britannique est entrée en
vigueur ce dimanche
certains ont été pris de court je
comprends pourquoi ils l'ont fait je
pense qu'il est très important d'arrêter
la propagation mais c'est vraiment
ennuyeux qui n'y a eu absolument aucun
avertissement
j'ai réservé ce vol depuis des semaines
et hier soir ils m'ont soudainement dit
qu'il fallait se mettre en quarantaine
qu'il n'y avait rien à faire je ne peux
pas aller travailler
je dois vous savez trouver des gens pour
faire des courses pour moi alors oui
c'est un peu dévastateurs
je comprends pourquoi c'est important
ironie de l'histoire la mesure touche
aussi le ministre britannique des
transports
actuellement en espagne selon le sunday
times grant shapps sa appris la nouvelle
par téléphone depuis son lieu de
vacances une absence de coordination qui
suscite de nombreuses moqueries et
critique à l'égard de la politique du
gouvernement britannique
face au co vite 19 plusieurs ministres
du gouvernement savait probablement à
l'avant ce qu'il était possible qu'une
quarantaine soit imposée aux vacanciers
de retour d'espagne mais apparemment
personne n'a pris la peine de prévenir
grant shapps ce malgré la stupéfaction
créée par la nouvelle le gouvernement
britannique assure avoir pris une
décision à la hauteur du risque encouru
des biens les données que nous avons
obtenus sur les cas en espagne était le
vendredi vous les compiler évidemment
tout au long de la journée ils eurent un
grand saut dans toute l'espagne
continentale
nous avons ensuite évaluer la situation
hier après midi nous avons pris la
décision aussi rapidement que possible
et nous ne pouvons pas nous excuser de
l'avoir fait où nous devons être
capables de prendre des mesures rapides
et effectives en particulier au niveau
local ou au niveau international en ce
concerne l'espagne un pays particulier
où nous voyons que nous devons agir
sinon nous risquons une réfection
royaume uni
éventuellement une deuxième vague puis à
nouveau confinement
en attendant cette mesure fragilise un
peu plus le secteur du tourisme en
espagne qui représentent 11 % de
l'économie nationale